new cad files for the iphone 14 pro max
were just leaked and these look
absolutely insane and this is so
exciting because the source is perhaps
one of the most reliable sources in
terms of cad files and he gave us a full
list of the detailed measurements which
actually adds to these being legitimate
so before i get into explaining all the
details all the measurements what
differences you should expect compared
to the current iphone 13 pro max with
these new ones i've gotta go through how
legitimate this source is and of course
that is shrimp apple pro yes that sounds
kind of funny but he's actually fairly
reliable if you didn't already know
shrimp apple pro is actually the very
first one to release this new exclusive
leak of the dual camera cutout that
we've been seeing everywhere and all the
leaked renders and everything else
confirmation from ross young saying that
we will be getting the dual cutouts it
actually came from shrimp as you can see
back in july 8th yes july that's before
the iphone 13 came out he released this
exclusive leak and basically nobody paid
attention to it until recently so he was
actually the first one and then to add
to his exclusivity
he actually posted this right here and
if you translate it you can see that
it's actually an invoice from apple in
taiwan their taiwan branch so they
actually sent him an invoice which means
he has some sort of connection with the
supply chain and that he actually
explained the leak saying that this is
only for the pro models 6.1 inch and 6.7
inch and he said that it's actually
flipped so this view is from the back so
if you flip it over that's how you get
the renders that we're all expecting and
that everybody expecting so this guy was
right about what everybody agrees on way
back then and then going further on
august 10th he revealed the lineup for
the iphone 14 of course the 14 the 14
max the 14 pro and the 14 pro max and
only after that we got confirmation from
ross young and other sources that this
will in fact be the lineup so he was
correct about this as well but for
further evidence way back on january
13th there were some leaks of the iphone
se design showing the face id notch and
basically the iphone 10r design for the
new iphone sc and he said this is sus
hold your expectations and he was right
because the iphone se that we got was
extremely disappointing it was basically
the same design as before so he was
right again and then going even further
back on may 27 of 2021 last year he said
there was a new model arriving in early
development and only recently in january
he confirmed that it was the iphone 14
pros display that started development
way back then so he does have some sort
of connection with the display industry
in the supply chain he even gave us the
code name for the iphone 14 pro max
testing panel
d854 so we're gonna have to confirm that
when it actually comes out and he also
gave us the actual code name for the
iphone itself
d73 well the 13 pro was d63 and then i
don't know if you remember a couple of
weeks back we got some updated renders
and cads showing that the actual dual
cutouts are going to be larger and
bigger than people expected so a lot of
people were disappointed but guess what
shrimp pointed out that way back in
august of last year he said that the
cutouts will be weirdly big chungus
and he showed yes it's going to be
weirdly big and people were surprised a
couple weeks ago when they saw those new
renders but he knew about it way back
then in august and then of course long
after shrimp made those exclusive leaks
mark german came out and agreed with him
saying that there's gonna be a hole
punch size notch coming in the fall with
the new iphone 14 range which is really
nice to have mark's approval and then
finally this brings us to the cad files
that he just leaked and i want to make a
big deal about this because these are so
far the most
detailed cad file renders that i've seen
so far so let's start with the very
first one as you can see
we have the dual cutout right here and
it looks very clean actually just
looking at it now i'm actually really
excited i think the real iphone 14 pro
that apple gives us is gonna look really
really good with this design and there's
an interesting detail here that he
mentioned that's actually the earpiece
speaker being considerably thinner than
it is on the 13 pro in this render now
of course right here we have a little
bit of an angle shot and this confirms
another thing the basic chassis or the
frame of the iphone looks like it's
going to remain completely unchanged the
same design we're not getting that new
flush design with the glass in the front
glass in the back looks like that might
be for the iphone 15 lineup so the
chassis remaining unchanged and then
boom
look at that that is a massive
looking camera bump yes it looks like
it's getting bigger and then of course
we have the full
design right here and one thing i want
to point out is that if you look very
closely at the bottom you will see a
lightning port yes that's the same
lightning that we already have and now
let's get into
those detailed specs that he gave us
starting from the top we have the actual
dimensions of the iphone 14 pro max
model itself but going down to the bezel
this is where it gets very very
interesting it says 1.9
millimeters for the new bezel compared
to
2.42 millimeters on the 13 pro max yes
the bezels are getting slimmer about 20
slimmer which is gonna be a pretty big
deal it's going to make it look more
immersive but here is the craziest part
looking at the height of the earpiece it
will now be
0.57 millimeters compared to
1.52 on the 13 pro max that's almost
three times slimmer they're making it
wider as well so the earpiece is gonna
be wider but thinner so that way they
can still get the awesome quality
through there now he also gave us
dimensions of the punch holes the right
and the left they're gonna have the same
diameter on both sides but it looks like
the distance of the cutouts from the top
of the screen is gonna be
higher so that means that they're gonna
be dropped down a little bit compared to
the current cameras within the notch and
then moving on to the camera bump it is
actually going to be bigger this time
with the difference from the glass to
the top of the camera bump being 4.18
millimeters that's actually going to be
15
larger or protruding more compared to
the 13 pro max so it's not going to be
that big of a difference but it will
definitely stick out more and i do
believe that the camera bump itself is
going to be larger compared to the 13
pro max so this is going to be a beefy
camera bump but of course that's because
we're expecting a 48 megapixel camera
that can shoot ak video i actually just
did a video on that recently so
definitely check it out and then finally
we have the flash and the lidar and
those dimensions 6.9 millimeters and 6.5
they seem to be exactly the same as we
already have so we might not get any
differences in terms of those two shrimp
actually gave us a bunch of other
details and i can honestly trust in what
he has to say so back in january he said
that the iphone 14 non-pro models are
gonna have a more refined notch that is
not any smaller they're gonna have
surprisingly a bigger camera hole which
he's assuming was for the upgraded
camera with wider view potentially
center stage if that is true that means
that all of the iphone 14s are getting
the new 12 megapixel ultra wide camera
that we got on the new ipad models and
that's actually very exciting
and as far as the 14 models the bezels
will be staying the same thickness so
the pro models will be getting thinner
bezels but these will stay the same so
that's going to kind of help
differentiate them and then going even
further he also let us know that we're
getting the same ceramic shield glass as
last year at least on the iphone 14
regular models i'm not sure about the
pros but then
he did say that the iphone 14 pro models
are confirmed to have eight gigabytes of
ram and here is another downside he has
just confirmed april 5th
that there will not be usb type-c on the
new iphone 14 which is extremely
disappointing but once again going back
to shrimp i'm very confident in this
source i think he does have some really
solid connections especially since he
was the first one to show the dual
cutout design and now everybody believes
in it and especially since these new
renders and cats are just so detailed
and they look really really good i
believe this is exactly what we're gonna
see with the iphone 14 pro max let me
know what you think about all of this
and these cats down in the comments
section below hopefully you enjoyed this
video and if you did definitely check
out the 48 megapixel camera video i made
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]